for many of America's senior citizens
social isolation was a problem long
before the pandemic struck now with many
confined to their homes it's become an
even greater concern but the same
technology that's helped much of society
connect in recent months may offer a
partial remedy and as Barry Petersen
reports some dedicated young people are
helping seniors to bridge the digital
divide while learning a few lessons of
their own they had to pull me here
kicking and screaming as my children
have said mom we were pulling you into
the next century and I said I'm just
getting used to the last one but okay
come on welcome to eighty nine-year-old
margaret i coughs first ever zoom comb
so I am learning and I had a great deal
of help from Gentek generation tech was
co-founded by Zachary Wang so Zach how
does it feel to hear that even in the
age of the coronavirus and people being
isolated you're still helping people
reach other people yeah I think it's
quite cool to know that this generation
at least is being taken care of and that
we can do something at its time for
other people we're all gonna compete in
this massive game of trivia this is how
generation Tek worked before the
pandemic
you seem to find the right section in
town high school volunteers visiting the
Holly Creek retirement community every
Saturday
like Zachary they come from Cherry Creek
High School in nearby Greenwood Village
Colorado their mission introducing the
newest technology to the oldest
generation do I want Spotify on my ed
Van Bramer is a retired doctor who sees
good health coming from these good deeds
I think it all is related around stress
the amount of stress that we have living
today is one of the causes of the rates
of heart disease strokes and so forth
high blood pressure and all of those
things that go along with the pressure
and the stress that everybody faces so I
say the more you do to broaden your
knowledge the more you do to be
interactive the more you do to use your
senses the better things work plus you
get to get rid of the stress of not
knowing how to get your printer to work
absolutely try putting it on for Ruth
get some dinner a first ever journey
using virtual reality she hiked Zion
National Park was but the two
generations have more in common than
they may realize a shared epidemic of
loneliness older people because spouses
or friends have died Rachel Cohen is
director of linkages a group promoting
activities between young and old to
combat social isolation research is
showing that the impacts of loneliness
is you can equate it to smoking 15
cigarettes a day
seriously absolutely it is worse than
obesity when we look at it from a
physical health perspective and surveys
show jimsy ages 18 to 22 are considered
the loneliest Americans in part because
they don't interact with others in
person does
this program help you understand the
need for actual people to be actual
friends with yeah so I think that social
media gives us this cocoon this shell
and I think that working with the order
those in generation tech you get to you
know get into that zone where you're not
just focused on yourself so you're
focused on solving that specific you
know maybe that specific tech problem
but in that process you're creating
those new relationships you're creating
those like bonds that might be
surprising to you um and I think that
just gives us a whole new perspective on
what it means to be able to truly
connect with someone what it means to be
able to connect with our society the
pandemic has made this kind of personal
help impossible at the moment but the
work goes on every week we work with
residents on their technology issues the
generation tech students hosted a
webinar on how to navigate technology
and social media and there are some
lessons that have to be lived to be
learned like margaret icon who has been
listening to her church service by phone
and will now attempt by zoom one big
change I'm sure they will all say you
now have to get dressed come to church
on Sunday you can't come in your pajamas
anymore
for CBS this morning Saturday very
Peterson and I've seen this happen in
I've seen it in action in places like
Harlem where at the Kennedy Community
Center you have teenagers working with
elders in that community brought
together by a women's group called the
Greater New York links it is just
amazing to watch in practice I mean half
the time you really do just need
somebody to show you how to do it I know
my mom's gonna be mad that I'm saying
for her but with her trying to teach her
how to do something it's hard to tell
her over the phone but there's a way to
do it once you get her there she's good
she's good she knows tick tock oh gosh
we don't before we don't yet it it
really is so much worse right now though
- with the pandemic as you have parents
and grandparents who were already maybe
isolated or alone to begin with and may
have lost friends and then they can't
spend time with others during what's
happening right now that stat Michelle
we both kind of gasped I don't know if
you did the 15 cigarettes a day
comparing that that that's what that
loneliness factor is like that's all
foods just awful yeah the stress of that